bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors aujourd'hui un petit
paléo newsflash petite émission pour
parler de deux articles j'ai pas
l'intention de faire des paléo news
toutes les semaines mais c'est juste que
quand il ya des choses commenté dans
l'actualité scientifique ou des choses
qui n'ont pas été suffisamment commenté
à mon avis dans l'actualité scientifique
et bien je vais me faire un devoir de
vous les présenter
ne suis-je pas généreux alors on va
commencer par cet article qui à mon sens
n'a pas eu suffisamment de couverture
médiatique c'est à un article sur la
taille du megalodon ni plus ni moins et
la raison pour laquelle il n'a pas reçu
beaucoup de couverture médiatique c'est
ce petit mot le mot clé le mot revisité
pourquoi parce que quand on nous raconte
que megalodon était vachement plus gros
que prévu ça il ya du monde mais quand
on penser pour nous dire qu'en fait gros
ils n'étaient pas si gros que sa balle a
tout de suite c'est moins vendeur
donc moi je vais vous en parler parce
que quand même c'est une c est un
article qui est assez intéressant et
donc il a été publiée cet été en août
2019 par kenshoo shimada qui est un
spécialiste japonais des des requins et
notamment du megalodon qui a déjà publié
de nombreux articles sur le sujet donc
c'est un article qui est vraiment passé
complètement sous le radar je crois
qu'il a ya à peine eu de couverture
médiatique en anglais en tout cas j'en
ai pas vu passer c'est vraiment il y a
vraiment fallu que je cherche à propos
de cet article pour en trouver et en
france s est complètement passée c'est
complètement passée inaperçue voilà mais
bon c'est de la recherche plutôt
sérieuse est basée sur deux des choses
plutôt simple à envisager donc dû c'est
pour ça que je vous ai que je voulais
vous en parlez donc dans l'introduction
il nous ils nous rappellent évidemment
toutes les tailles démentiel qui ont été
estimés pour le megalodon citant même la
gelée mis en en
en jaune le livre the egg
enfin je crois que c'est la suite du
livre aux maigres ou une des suites du
livre the mèdes qui donne 25 mètres de
longueur pour le megalodon ce qui n'est
toujours pas un record puisque la la
plus grande longueur qu'il a pu trouver
apparemment dans la littérature de
fiction ses 61 m donc il a encore il
était encore loin du compte l'auteur de
the egg et dans la littérature
scientifique d'ailleurs pour la
d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas s'il faut
25 m comparé à ce que ce qu'on a dans
certaines dans certains pans de la
littérature scientifique puisque ici on
a voilà 24 mètres qui traînent dans la
littérature scientifique donc voilà
c'est méga ce mec finalement c'est pas
c'était pas si fou que ça comparé à ce
qu'on peut lire dans la littérature mais
voilà donc lui il a décidé d'obtenir une
taille une estimation de taille de
megalodon un peu plus précise et alors
ce qu'il faut bien préciser dans cet
article c'est qui ce qu'il va obtenir
c'est une taille de megalodon maximum et
pas moyenne 1 ça c'est très très
important à comprendre dès maintenant
pour une raison très simple c'est que
son estimation de taille pour que son
estimation de taille marche en fait va
falloir qu'ils utilisent les dents
antérieures qui sont les dans les plus
grandes
et comme on n'a jamais retrouvé deux
mâchoires complète de megalodon bas le
seul moyen de savoir lesquels des dents
on a retrouvé de façon isolée sont des
dents antérieures basse et de prendre
les plus grandes et les plus symétrique
voyez que plus on va vers l'arrière plus
les dents deviennent petit et
asymétrique donc le seul moyen de
d'appliquer sa méthode de mesure c'est
d'identifier les dents les plus
antérieure qui sont les dans les plus
grandes et les dents les plus symétrique
donc qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va
aller à travers les collections de
différents musées au moins au moins
trois ou quatre
si je me si ma mémoire est exacte et il
va il a cherché les plus grandes dents
les plus symétrique pour pouvoir
appliquer sa méthode de mesure donc déjà
il faut savoir ça c'est que il n'a pas
pu finalement de méthodologiquement il
ne peut pas utiliser des dents de taille
moyenne il faut qu'ils l'utilisent les
plus grandes
et ça déjà ça va nous deux ça donne un
billet considérable c'est que ce qu'on
va avoir c'est la taille la plus grande
possible de megalodon est pas la taille
moyenne de megalodon voilà ça c'est la
première chose à savoir la deuxième
chose à savoir c'est quelle espèce qui
l'utilisent l'espèce moderne qui
l'utilisent c'est évidemment le grand
requin blanc puisque megalodon n'a pas
d'équivalent moderne donc voilà il va
donc utiliser car carreaux dont 4/4
liasse alors c'est contestable puisque
megalodon maintenant on le sait n'est
pas directement relié à carcassonne
carcharias mais c'est un peu on fait ce
qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
j'ai envie de dire et en l'occurrence
car cardon ça reste le l'équivalent
écologique le plus proche de megalodon
c'est-à-dire un méga prédateurs de
mammifères marins même si en
l'occurrence les mammifères man
megalodon c'était plus des baleines que
des phoques mais bon va bien falloir
faire comme je dis il faut bien faire
avec ce qu'on a
donc sans à la limite faut savoir qu'il
ya des limitations à ce niveau là mais
ce sont des limitations qui sont j'ai
envie de dire incontournable donc
donc il faut simplement en être
conscient et savoir qu'il va y avoir une
petite marge d'erreur quoi et justement
là l'une des grandes choses avec cette
technique qu'il a utilisée c'est que il
réduit assez bien la marge d'erreur
alors ici vous allez voir comment il a
fait ce qu'il a fait c'est grosso merdo
un produit en croit mais en plus en plus
sophistiqués quoi c'est à dire que vous
avez la hauteur de la plus grande dans
de mégalo dont vous avez la hauteur de
la plus grande dans 2
d'un requin blanc et puis vous faites le
produit en croit vous connaissez la
longueur du requin blanc vous faites un
produit en croit bon ben il ajuste
multipliez ça
par par un très grand nombre de points
voilà un très grand nombre de données
sur les grands requins blancs et un plus
grand nombre de dents de megalodon pour
obtenir une courbe comme celle ci donc
en fait il a même fait plusieurs courbes
vous pouvez voir et finalement il a
utilisé celle qui donnait le moins de
marge d'erreur est celle qui donne le
moins de marge d'erreur c'est celle qui
sont basés sur la juste eu mans sur la
hauteur des dents antérieures supérieur
donc les grands a ici vous voyez que la
marge d'erreur est quand même moindre
que quand on utilise la halle et dans
les dents antérieures inférieur et que
là le le rideau de dispersion ici est
bien plus grand donc est ce qui fait
bien il utilise plein de plein dedans de
carcaradec carcharias dont il mesure la
longueur
il utilise les la longueur du corps des
des grands requins blancs correspondant
et puis il trace ses courbes et il voit
en fait qu'elle dans marche le mieux et
comme je le disais ce sont les dents
antérieures supérieur qui marche le
mieux pour prédire la longueur du corps
à partir de la longueur des dents parce
que c'est ça l'idée c'est d'arriver à
prédire la longueur du corps à partir de
la longueur des dents parce que
megalodon on n'a que des dents isolées
et du coup il a réussi à faire ça il
trouve une corrélation extrêmement forte
vous voyez qu'il ya très très peu de
dispersion autour de ses courbes
donc il ya quand même une marge d'erreur
qui est très très réduite
mais le problème c'est que quand on
arrive en haut des courbes quand on
arrive dans l'est dans les gammes de
taille qu'on s'attend à trouver pour
megalodon donc autour de 15 et 20 mètres
ou voire même 25 mètres mais en fait
c'est ses courbes se disperse fortement
d'où le d'où l'intérêt d'utiliser la
mesure la plus précise possible parce
que évidemment si vous utilisez cette
courbe là pour une dent qui fait 14 cm
vous avez trouvé un megalodon de 20
mètres mais si vous utilisez cette
courbe est là pour une banque qui fait
14 cm vous trouvez un mégalo de moins de
15 mètres donc il faut vraiment utiliser
des courbes qui sont les
et qui ont le moins dispersé possible
c'est pour ça qu'il a focalisé sur les
danses supérieur et donc en utilisant
ses courbes sur les dents supérieures
qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent il calcule que
le megalodon devait faire aux alentours
de 14 m voilà donc sachant qu'un bon
gros requin blanc ça fait aux alentours
de s'y mettre donc je crois que c'est ce
qu'il dit un petit peu plus loin
le requin blanc et le requin blanc donc
voilà j'ai mis un peu de temps à le
trouver mais c'est là qu'il le dit voilà
le requin blanc qui fait à peu près 6
mètres de longueur totale donc ça vous
fait un megalodon qui est à peu près
deux fois un petit peu plus que deux
fois plus grand que la taille d'un alors
ça fait la taille maximum de megalodon
qui est deux fois plus grande que la
taille d'un requin blanc moyens voilà
donc ça c'est important encore une fois
à comparer ces on estime bien la taille
maximum de megalodon dans ce cas là donc
14 mètres de long à peu près bon ça vous
fait toujours un requin tout à fait
correct de toute façon rien que par la
taille des dents on sait qu'il ya que
megalodon était de toute façon le plus
grand des prédateurs marins
enfin le plus grand des requins qui ait
pu exister donc c'est normal qu'on
trouve une grande taille mais voilà ce
nouvel article donc nous dit 14 mètres
donc assez loin des 20 mètres des 30
mètres même des fois qu'on peut lire
dans la littérature
le deuxième article c'est un article à
propos de tyrannosaurus rex donc
tyrannosaurus rex qui fait encore parler
de lui vous avez peut-être vu où aller
le voir d'ici quelques jours ou quelques
semaines dans l'est dans les nouvelles
dans la presse dans les médias quelque
chose qui vous dira que tyrannosaurus
rex était capable de broyer des voitures
avec sa mâchoire est alors non pas que
je remette ça en question 1
mais par contre ce que je remets en
question c'est qu'il cite cet article
donc ce n'est cette nouvelle étude
publiée par khost tenez on retrouve
holiday dont j'avais parlé dans le
dernier au lit des huit maires
d'ailleurs dont j'avais parlé dans le
dernier paléo news donc encore la même
équipe qui frappe à nouveau
et donc il cite cet article pour
soutenir cette affirmation en tout cas
ce gros titre bien plus ta clique
tyrannosaurus rex était capable de
broyer des voitures encore faut-il
encore faut-il que cet article parle de
ça mais ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas
le cas du tout cet article il est tout à
propos de la
compétences kinetic du crâne de
tyrannosaurus rex
voilà c'est ce qu'on lit dans l'abstract
ici et c'est tout simplement en fait il
ya il y a dans le crâne de tyrannosaure
des articulations interne
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de ça voilà des ce qu'on appelle des
joints kinetic donc comme chez les
oiseaux d'ailleurs donc il y a dans le
crâne des joints kinetic qui rajoute de
la mobilité à l'intérieur du crâne et
vous avez les mêmes
en fait chez tyrannosaure que chez
certains oiseaux donc voici les joints
kinetic en question et du coup ça ça
rajoute de la flexibilité au crâne de
tyrannosaurus rex alors on vous dira que
c'était pour qu'il puisse ouvrir la
gueule plus grand donc c'est ce qu'ils
ont c'est ce qu'il tente de montrer avec
ces images là mais en fait lors leurs
hypothèses de base c'est que plus on
rajoute de la mobilité à l'intérieur du
crâne et plus ça rajoute de la fragilité
au crâne
d'où là d'où la question est ce qu'il
était vraiment capable de développer
autant de puissance dans sa mâchoire
quand l'imaginent est en fait la réponse
de cet article en fait ils contournent
on va dire la réponse la réponse qu'il
donne dans cet article et est assez
marrante c'est en fait ils disent que
s'ils étaient capables de développer
autant de puissance alors s'est joint
kinetic ne fonctionnait pas et donc ils
font l'hypothèse en fait que ces joints
kinetic n'était pas du tout des joints
kinetic en fait c'étaient des points
fixes du crâne
ce qui me semble un peu bizarre comme
conclusion ce qui me semble un peu plus
bizarres alors la raison c'est que quand
ils font leurs simulations donc ils ont
utilisé des éléments une analyse en
éléments finis et puis du coup il trouve
qu'effectivement ces joints kinetic sont
des joints sont des zones de très fortes
il ya beaucoup de contraintes en fait
qui s'exerce à ces niveaux là donc ce
sont des zones très fragile en fait donc
s'il était vraiment capable de
développer autant de puissance bas ça
aurait pété voilà le crâne aurait cassé
à ce niveau là et ça ça marche pas donc
ils disent qu'il y avait pas de loi il y
avait il dit ce qui avait pas de
mobilité
bon ça me semble ça me semble une
conclusion assez assez assez radical ac
contre intuitive au final puisque on
aurait pu dire bah non s'il y avait des
joints kinetic comme ça alors ça veut
dire que
son son crâne n'était peut-être pas
capable de développer autant de
puissance mais il semblerait qu'en fait
leur raisonnement c'est que le laisser
zone justement en rouge là sont
tellement sensibles en fait que si on
considère que qu'il y avait joint
kinetic à cet endroit alors il aurait à
peine pu mordre en fait ils sont ils
sont très très loin en fait delà de la
résistance structurelle de du crâne et
du cou du coup ils font des hypothèses
concernant en fait la disposition des
muscles la disposition des os et des
cartilages et comment en fait c'est coc
muscler ses cartilages empêchait
finalement s'est joint kinetic de bouger
ou s'est joint cinétique si vous
préférez si vous préférez le mot
cinétique kinetic le l'idée étant que
voilà l'article du coup contrairement à
ce que la presse en dit cet article
n'est pas du tout à propos de
tyrannosaure est incapable de développer
une puissance capable d'écraser une
voiture cet article il est juste à
propos de la de la mobilité interne du
crâne voilà et son évaluation en fait
l'un qu'on sait la l'incohérence qui lie
à entre le fait qu'on observe des joints
interne à l'intérieur du crâne et le
fait que justement on est hypothétique
et qu'il fa qu'ils puissent développer
autant de puissance donc loin même de
dire que le tyrannosaure était capable
de développer énormément de puissance
dans ce
dans sa morsure en fait cet article le
remet en question il remet très
franchement en question même si à la fin
finalement il
il esquive in extremis le la bastos en
disant ouais non mais c'est bon en fait
il n'y avait pas de y avait pas de
mobilité interne façon c'est pas
possible il aurait pu parce que sinon
ils auraient pu développer autant de
puissance bah oui mais n'empêche que
vous avez mis le doigt sur un truc là
donc
donc voilà c'est un article qui est
plutôt intéressant même si comme je
disais à la fin la conclusion ce dérive
un peu sur wii mais en fait non voilà
oui mais en fait non et voilà nos
observations elle marche pas parce qu'en
fait il y avait pas de joint kinetic du
tout et puis dernière petite nouvelle et
encore une fois un peu d'auto promotion
c'est moi même ma collaboratrice sur la
chaîne sophie et mon étudiante aliénor
qui venons de publier un article dans la
revue fossile donc le magazine français
fossile donc kivu qui est trouvable un
peu partout un peu partout dans l'est
chez les marchands de journaux quoi vous
pouvez acheter dans les grandes surfaces
donc nous venons de publier dans ce
magazine alors je sais pas s'il se cet
article que nous avons écrit sera
accessible dans le prochaine édition
donc celle qui sort en octobre
ou bien dans la suivante celle qui sort
en novembre donc vous pouvez vous pouvez
d'ores et déjà allé voir l'édition
d'octobre voir s'il ya des articles qui
vous intéressent voilà c'est une revue
de paléontologie amateur et on n'y a
publié un article donc sur l'exploration
du caroux c'est à dire l'exploration des
fossiles sud-africain donc c'est un peu
pensé comme une mini aventures une mini
exploration en fait comme un road trip à
travers l'afrique du sud et à travers
les fossiles qu'on y trouve donc c'est
ça fait beaucoup et qu au projet trine
axe alors vous voyez qu'il ya encore des
corrections à apporter un puisque ça
c'est une c'est une épreuve de l'article
avant d'aller sous presse
mais voilà donc c'est une revue que je
vous encourage à les voir et pourquoi
pas acheter si vous le coeur vous en dit
voilà c'est très intéressant et comme
j'ai dit ces écrits par des par des
amateurs passionnés donc
c'est tout bon voilà c'était un petit
paléo newsflash merci de l'avoir suivi
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
sur notre chaîne